les garçons oui si vous passez
on était juste allé faire quelques
courses c'est tout
vraiment désolé maître il voulait aller
manger une pizza j'ai essayé de les
raisonner on est fait comme des rats
rejeté par la société et qu'on pouvait
faire tout ce qu'on veut
vous feriez quoi allez au lycée ou
sortir avec une fille vous imaginez le
train
de championne de karaté je veux
absolument tout savoir sur vous et ben
notre père est pas du tout enragé tu
viens de me convaincre que c'en
est par la récente série de crime
permettrait par Superfly personne n'a
jamais vu son visage
tous ceux qui croient son regard
é Superfly après tout le monde nous
trouvera sympa il nous acceptera
sous le pont de
brooklynamique
vous êtes des petites tortues c'est ça
j'y crois pas il y a d'autres Mythos bon
alors vous rouler avec nous
des humains ne nous aimeront jamais
donc on va s'arranger pour que les
mutants dominent la terre
d'humain ça dégage ah ouais le scénario
qui tue
on pourra pas l'arrêter mais on doit
essayer
ça c'est une entrée qui fait mouche de
tocard
s
le courage et toi Léonardo le sens de
l'honneur
[Musique]